hey what's up guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at the
instrumental class and we basically
integrated that into Hegel's check out
that video if you haven't already the
point of that of course is to be able to
give us kind of our the results of our
profiles we now have a profile inside
hazel that we can use to see how
different areas of our application how
long they actually take and we can also
visualize them in Chrome Tracy so we
we've got that system in hazel now
that's what we left off in the previous
episode but now we have to actually use
the system and it's kind of one thing to
just have that system to write a system
like that and then you know just have it
around but then the other function is to
actually use it and knowing how to use
it is somewhat difficult I think it's
something that takes a little bit time
to get used to because there's a bit of
a balance the thing is in general when
you're profiling you're gathering a lot
of data right you're gathering every
single frame a whole like bunch of
functions technically speaking right
this could mean that your JSON file
which contains all of your profile and
results at runtime could end up being
like hundreds of megabytes if you're not
careful that's dangerous because it will
take a whole lot of time to actually
then visualize that data and look at it
so you want to kind of be conservative
with how you do this usually you
probably don't want to have a running
profile that just runs forever right so
in other words at the moment what we
have is a session that we kind of begin
as soon as we kind of run an app run
right so in other words we have our
startup set and we have our run time
session and our ending session inside
that entry point header file last time
we added Kurt that basically surrounded
our entire application run function with
an actual profiling session which means
that as soon as we run our application
it starts an actual like file output
right at a profiling session sounds up a
file output and then every single timing
that happens inside that run loop of our
application actually gets put into that
file again not ideal because you know if
you think about it we're running 60
frames per second at a minimum this
vsync of this
you're on a computer with like 144 Hertz
you're running 144 frames per second
probably so think about that right so in
other words sandbox video updates
getting here 144 times every second
that's timing results for that function
being put into a file 144 times per
second that's just one function what
about only difference what about all the
different scopes what about all the
other areas that you could possibly in
instrument right and probably that we're
going to take a look at doing right now
that's a whole lot of data it just
becomes huge and so because of that you
want to be conservative with it now now
what I would say is that in a real world
example if you actually had a game and
you were actually using this kind of
JSON style of profiling right you
probably would want to have a button
that you can press sometime during
runtime
that will start a profile and then will
stop a profile so in other words two
buttons start stopped that way you can
be like oh right I'm off to a part that
I know lags I want to know why it takes
time I'm gonna hit start I'm gonna go
through that section where the
performance is not very good then I'm
gonna hit stop brilliant I've got my
profile for that kind of critical
section that doesn't run very well the
other thing you could do is if the game
in general is not running very well
let's just say you know your frame rates
constantly 17 frames frames per second
or somehow that you know something's
wrong you don't want to have this time
and going the whole time right you're
just in a in a place maybe in a 17
frames per second you want to know why
you can make a little button that will
profile say the next ten frames so the
next second right so the next like 60 or
17 frames or however many frames right
and then what you have is a file that
just contains like 60 frames worth of
data that way you're not dealing with
just a whole bunch of data for your
entire application every time because
that's impossible to even find problem
areas right if you run if you play
through a game for three minutes
you know how much data you're gonna have
if you just leave it running the whole
time too much right now when on it that
we're not really at that stage at the
moment obviously everything is pretty
clean and simple
for us but I'm just saying that in
general you probably want to extend the
system to include the things that I have
kind of said are required and again not
hard to do whatsoever
we don't have frame counters at the
moment some of the wise we can't get the
current frame of our program which is
trivial to add obviously but basically
if you are keeping keeping track of
every frame that gets rented which you
should then you can easily just create a
button that basically will begin a
session and then as soon as you know
every frame or whatever it might check
or whatever and it was just end the
session as soon as the frame count
reaches a certain amount of frames that
way you know that you've got like
exactly ten frames of data exactly 100
frames of data however many you want so
that's something that's trivial to add
maybe you guys can add that just as a
pull request or just into like I'm going
or something so I can be like I want to
profile the next ten frames and put it
into this file you know for example that
could be something cool to actually
investigate something that we'll
probably add in the future anyway but
yeah for now we're just gonna stick with
what we've got because it's not gonna
get to the point where it's unmanageable
and it's not like we're running our
applications like 10 minutes at a time
but yeah that's kind of how that works
so let's go through the engine and think
about where to put these instrumentation
this.h their profile function macro
because that's really the hard part is
deciding ok this is this is the
structure of our program how are we
going to lay it out inside this JSON
file and also I think we had a problem
last time where the timer was returning
identical results if we run it twice in
succession so in other words if we start
the timer and then start a timer
immediately after that since we're using
the kind of asset the standard C++
library we're asking what the current
time is by using that you know high
resolution clock now function right
sometimes it gives us the exact same
number twice in a row and that's a
problem and we're gonna we might have to
address that as well probably we'll have
to anyway let's dive in take a look
before we do that huge thank you of
course to all the patrons that made this
series possible panels left the show
knows the best way to help support this
series you'll get access to exclusive
videos as well as exclusive car
for hazel but I've already written for
like the 3d rendering and there's like a
Vulcan renderer as well that I'm going
to release maybe I've already released
it but time you see this video I'm not
sure but anyway huge thank you of course
to everyone who made this series
possible okay let's go through our code
so at the moment we've just laid out
these profile functions over here inside
sandbox which is fine you know you want
that stuff in sandbox as well it's just
supposed to see client user based code
as well obviously but we need to go
through the engine so where am I gonna
start I'm going to copy this I'm gonna
go to application or sleepy and we're
gonna take a look at this so application
is what creates node the application I
think it's quite important to have a
profile function here because obviously
you know we want to see when our
application starts up how long
everything takes so no it's creating the
window right that's something that's
probably important now what does this do
this actually creates a windows window
you know this is the window create
function it will just return this it's
probably not worth putting a timer into
here you could but we don't really need
that level of granularity I think so
inside windows window where we actually
have this constructor and where is that
oh right okay I see this is inside
Windows Windows so maybe inside the
windows with my constructor maybe inside
a nice will kind of stick these edge the
profile function we might do more stuff
here in the future but generally if you
just have a function that calls another
function you brought we don't want to
profile it I am in this case but it's
kind of just up to you I think at that
point because I think that will expand
that in the future since we're here
let's take a look at like for example
how long shutdown takes we're not going
to worry about the callbacks on update
is definitely important context swap
buffers I definitely want to see that
how long swapping the buffers if the
OpenGL context takes since we're here I
also want to see how long initializing
the OpenGL context takes not really
concerned about a constructor let's see
what else is shutdown
okay what else are we doing here inside
the initialization cards so yes this is
what I was talking about in it which
we've done said vsync I what does that
actually do so
like full on I don't know what that does
that looks like something different so
it winter that just gets the winter
except swap intervals so what is out
here is context swap interval so that
where are we
context swap interval what is that
swap interval function and then we need
to get the windows context we're just
going to be quite difficult probably
without JFW code
Jeff W source win32 window maybe does
that do anything with swap interval nor
does the context do anything with
swapping tool
it's probably this oops
swap interval wgl so what does that do I
just want to see a case that actually
does call like a function that sets the
swapping Teufel been in there I just
thought maybe it actually did something
a little bit different along the lines
of like just caching result but it
doesn't so I guess I'm interested to see
how long that takes
so in other words what I'll do is to set
vsync I will also had in that HTML file
function went a little bit of a rabbit
hole there um okay and then yeah okay so
that looks pretty decent right and this
is kind of what is gonna be live so
we'll put one in the destructor as well
this is basically what this is gonna be
like it's gonna be going through your
code taking a look at things and seeing
what things you want there either for
structure or for profiling
sake right so in other words this can
also be used very easily or very nicely
to see what the structure of your
program is so we init the renderer and
then from there we spin off and do
render command in it which I will put
profile okay so when you get to render a
functions and this is another thing that
this doesn't support at this point but I
kind of don't want to see profiling
things for the renderer necessarily the
reason is the renderer does a lot of
stuff the renderer the frame to frame
renderer of your engine is going to be
doing a lot of things if you profile
every single command apart from slowing
down massively you're gonna have a lot
of extra data which is why I like to
something like a set profile your
blender or function or something like
that and then that's like an additional
level of profiling that you turn on you
know explicitly so that's not something
that just comes with this because
usually being able to see Arcade the
renderer is doing its rendering work is
sometimes enough because maybe you only
care about your actual application and
the fact that it might be doing some
calculation or whatever and you want to
see how that works right whereas if
you're specifically profiling the
renderer that's a different that's a
different ballgame so in other words you
probably don't want to profile things
like this right this is just
initialization code doesn't matter too
much I'll leave that here for now but
yeah stuff like this you know I would
leave that to the specific render a
profiler because that's gonna be a
little bit of a different game okay cool
so what does it the other end would do
and this renderer is this is more of
like a high-level renderer as you know
so it's different render a 2d in it so
we'll leave that here and then we get to
all this fun stuff so vertex array but
as you know buffer blah blah we can add
stuff here so vertex array create now
you know this again this does not need
to be profiled right because all this is
is a switch statement it selects the
right one this is this would be
pointless data to have inside your
profile well you probably want to see is
this right so when you actually create a
vertex array for example you know bright
might be two lines in a way where you
destroy it you bind it you unbind it you
know this kind of stuff
add vertex buffer and set that takes
birth again stuff that maybe you want to
add a specific renderer profile function
to but for now we're just going to keep
it as a as just H set a profile function
all right so that's the vertex array I
suspect we're just running to everything
else here so there's buffer create same
thing again we'll go into the actual
implement a
we'll skip the abstraction and we'll add
a profile function to basically all
these functions and this is cool because
it will see it will let us visualize
what we're actually doing it right so in
otherwise how many times do we call bind
unbind that's impossible to trap you
know just by eyeballing it I guess but
because we're profiling this apart from
being able to see how long it takes the
other huge benefit is that we can see
for example how many times do we
actually bind and unbind where does that
happen in our program at which stage
right we can see all of that because
we've kind of gathering metrics on that
which is really useful so index buff
I've done textures as well and shaders
not a really cool area that we can
profile so we'll add this stuff here and
yeah and yeah and yeah and said daughter
are gonna be fine
the other useful thing is this for
example this is SD bi large so this is
us actually loading our texture that's
pretty useful I would say so what I'll
do is I'll credible Scarpia and then
what I'll do is inside this curve
instead of edge that profile function
I'll do a set profile start right and
then what I'll do is I'll steal this
I'll steal this function signature right
and then you know we'll have our contest
City string rights just so that I know
what constructor it is right and then
I'll basically say that's dpi Lloyd
right
I mean that looks a little bit maybe
I'll do it s DPI alert in there I don't
know how else to share that maybe like
that so that was just kind of sure what
function is coming from and us actually
doing this so you don't know if you
still hate this we'll have to just pop
this up here and then
okay so that's us quickly just basically
profiling how long loading actually
takes which is useful because what we're
doing a bunch of opengl stuff here but I
want to see how long STV is taking to
load the image okay cool and then let's
see and what you could do by the way
this is other stuff that people kind of
neglect when the profiling is you know
with height channels it would be quite
useful for us to actually see how long a
profile takes or rather how long texture
loading takes based on these things now
we don't have a very good string format
on and here we have none actually but it
would be nice if we had a format string
formatter here that we could use so that
way we could actually only you know
format the string if we're going to be
profiling it because at this stage you
know it's not going to be easy for us to
look at that but in the future you know
with heightened channels in fact let's
do this maybe because I kind of am
interested in this to be honest so with
high AR but the elephant the other
reason we can't is because we actually
get that stuff from the texture so we
would need to have some kind of post
function here that actually tells us how
long it took so that's not really
possible in this case but yeah I mean if
there was a way well that definitely
it's the way we just have to build a
system for it but for us to be able for
us to be able to actually be like a gate
well in this previous thing we look at a
texture it was 1024 by 1024 and hey it
was RGB it took us this much time so a
little bit more data for you like for
you profiling done I sort of just like
you know we load a texture it took ten
milliseconds but then this one took off
a millisecond and then you have no idea
what why does that disparity so that's
why straight information is always good
alright I think that's it for texture
shada was the other important one so
OpenGL shader and then let's see yeah so
there's quite a lot of stuff in here I
seem to have lost everything for the
file function
rate file I'm interested in that
pre-processing obviously very
interesting piling is interesting
binding is interesting and uniform
uploading yeah I don't know if that's
that useful let's say that just calls
offload doesn't it like out I'll put one
inside step int I'll put one inside the
set functions but I won't put anything
inside the upload functions okay cool so
there we go the shade is done let's see
what else we have here that's it okay
so retro 2d obviously has one render a
2d shutdown I also put that in here the
inseam is nice and seen which does
nothing at the moment is also nice draw
quad draw quad draw quad and this okay
so that way we kind of know what we're
dealing with and well again you know
this probably not that useful
so we'll actually put it into the one
with the meet the reason is we're trying
to minimize the data as much as possible
we don't want to have extra function
functions being recorded if they don't
need to be recorded okay
it's that okay so that was inside where
application renderer emit we have the
iron gooey layer which again you know on
attach for example doesn't mind do we
set up stuff I'm interested in that for
sure
you know this stuff I'm not as
interested in that that will just fit
into into here on D Tasha's interesting
beginning is interesting and it's also
interesting so we can see how long that
takes
push over light yeah again this stuff
you know application destructor which
layer up push overlay that's kind of
interesting
now push lay
that is not pulling on attached oh okay
hang on push overlay layer stack pusher
like oh okay that is called inside
elastic I'm not sure how I feel about
that I don't think I added that card the
reason is I would expect application to
actually call that an don't attach
happens here as well the reason is that
it's just yeah it makes more sense for
it to be cold here
how does detach happens or pop layer
what does that even happen I don't think
we even support that at this point yeah
that should be changed I'm gonna change
that right now so laiona Tosh is gone
from both of these places because the
latest attack is just a data structure I
shouldn't be doing anything like that
and then inside push layout once this
can be pushed to the stack you should do
on attach in this case and then well
yeah they're both gonna do it so we'll
leave the detach that because I don't
think well I don't think we're actually
calling attached anywhere but the layer
stack should definitely not be the one
to do that
soleio and attach every island attached
and that only happens if I guess if it
finds it which is fair enough I guess
you could have a rule that this returns
whether or not it was able to pop the
layout but anyway cool sorry that didn't
break anything I don't think it did but
we have this here which is good we don't
need to profile the layer stack is this
is our structure on events yeah you
probably do want to profile that in all
seriousness just because you know that's
gonna do stuff that's gonna be
interesting this is definitely
interesting alright the run the loop of
our application you even might want to
call this profile scope and then be like
you know run loop or something like that
to that make it more obvious I'm just
gonna keep this I think application run
is fine the wrong loop every frame yes
sir this is interesting as well because
you probably want to break this down in
all seriousness there isn't being that
like you know your lair update so this
is like the lair update at the moment I
have no scope yet because we might add
more stuff
to not minimize for example I don't
think I'm good be doing anything if it's
minimized so let's move that up here
that's suspicious but that was down
there so this you know is all of our
layers being updated so you probably
want to add a profile start here and
just be like layup on update or
something like that or just you know
layout on updates I don't know I don't
know I don't want it I don't want it to
look like layer on update because that's
a different function but basically
layers layer stack on update I'll say
with a little bit of a space here not a
namespaces that you know it's not a
national function and then the on gooey
stuff yeah again like you know the on
I'm going rendering for all for
everything you know will basically say
layers on I'm around okay so we have all
of the I'm GU rendering we have this
yeah begin and end we've gone anyway and
then I get cool so again if you wanted
to you could also add a little bit of a
profile scope inside here which which
was basically your entire ROM loop right
so that's like one iteration of your
program running so I think I will put
here I'll just write run loop and then
this will be our actual loop right
so we have application run and then we
have our envelope on winter clothes and
resize it so resizes interesting for us
to look at because you know resizing
could take considerable time and we
definitely want to be aware of how long
it takes but I think that's about it for
application so at this point we kind of
drilled down and just went through the
Cole stack in a way and saw everything
that happened but another good strategy
is to literally just look at your files
alright so did we did we do everything
that we wanted to so because not
everything might be used I think we went
through pretty much everything logging
we definitely don't want to profile we
don't care about that too much
you know our orthographic camera mm-hmm
yeah maybe like recalculating the
and stuff like that we probably care
about as well as maybe set rejection the
reason is you probably want to be aware
of actually how long this stuff takes or
rather not how long it takes but how
often is called right if set projection
comes up way too often in our profiles
and why are we resetting the cameras
projection that that often you know
stuff like that the camera control oh
yeah I'm definitely interested in how
long that takes you know on update for
example and then on a fan maybe and then
you know Mouse crawl and then that stuff
that stuff's really interesting to look
at so we'll keep that in there render
command we won't touch for now around
Rover and touch we've done all this
stuff yeah everything looks pretty good
I think
that's pretty much all of Hazel so good
man the the UM the Youtube version of
hazel is tiny compared to the dev
version I must say I guess yeah there's
not much not much in here so yeah we're
doing it get a move on with this engine
I think because it is quite smaller I
thought all right sorry will leave
propel function here we'll get rid of
like this stuff we don't need to do this
because we've actually added profile
function to that function yeah for like
render a prep and then render a draw
again you know we're actually profiling
this stuff in here so we don't really
care too much about that I might
actually leave it in there why not
they'll be useful to look at and then on
an GUI render will also live leave
inside here so this is pretty cool I
think we've got quite a lot of stuff
here now sandbox on attack I'll
definitely profile and also on detach
even though there's nothing in here just
though we remember for the future I
think that's it and if we look at the
layer class like that doesn't have
anything worth profiling does it no not
really
okay cool awesome looks good let's run
this and I'm interested to see what kind
of data we get cuz now that we've gone
through and actually instrumented this
hopefully I didn't miss anything
critical once we see this will actually
see if we have or haven't missed
anything and then we'll be able to deal
with stuff accordingly okay so it still
runs flying obviously as you would
expect
let's actually press the close button
here so that we do the shutdown stuff
and let's take a look at the data that
we get
so okay so this is now 1.77 met much
more data in here we've got shut down
let's start by looking at startup okay
cool we have a lot of stuff here this is
definitely looking a bit better and also
my our kids my wsd kids are working on
like a last time which is good okay cool
so check this out so we've got windows
window in me it takes a lot of time look
at this so first of all look we have
this application thing what's over here
because there's something else so push
layer and application so this is the
application constructor what calls the
application constructor entry points the
way it gets we don't catch much about
that but basically this you know
altogether took 510 milliseconds so we
know that the the startup took 510
milliseconds if we want to see what that
actually was entry point begins and ends
the session this is everything
every time that we recorded within this
block so create application that's where
everything stems from grant application
gets actually implemented inside our own
kind of clients like cards so if you
wanted to client-side you could easily
add this into here and then you see from
where everything runs from but I think
that's pretty clear we don't need to do
that
so yeah windows window takes the
overwhelming majority of time and you
can see that at the end here we do like
the OpenGL context in it so I guess the
actual GL of TT construction of the
window takes the most time right and
again it's really cool that we can see
this now sir windows window and so what
I would do is actually kind of make sure
that that was the case so I would add a
I would add an H that for a false carp
into here and basically say GLW create
window right and again if we knew we
could add some parameters for example to
know which window we were creating by
printing the title and stuff like that
but we won't bother with that now so
yeah the first stage of this is
obviously to run this and see what we
get and then
stage is well we can go through and see
what areas in our visualization are like
lacking and then we can just kind of you
know add more instrumentation to get
more data on that so if we now drop in
our new start up we should see okay
it'll be a window this look quite a
block here it's what like 160
milliseconds what on earth are we doing
here this ecology all don't really need
I totally forgot about that so let's put
a let's put a fun let's put a scope in
here as well
and just for sanity's sake I'll check so
there's nothing else going on here I
think so this is just gelatin even it
okay cool so you can see how cool this
is like I love stuff like this don't get
me wrong
I'm profiling and doing all of this
stuff is really really cool to see
because apart from seeing what you're
actually doing in your program which you
can kind of forget the larger it gets
you can also definitely like make sure
that everything's going the way you want
to go and how long things are taking
it's really really cool so back here
let's grab their new profile the new
style okay good so you can see we're
actually filling this out now so
initially it was like Windows window
this is taking a lot of time what's
going on and now I can actually see that
okay well we're doing JFW
in it and we're doing create winter and
that's taking out that time in it takes
148 milliseconds which is considerable
right and then and I'm just looking at
this wall duration down here by the way
to see how long it takes
so 357 milliseconds to create a winter
quite a bit and then we're doing
Narendra in it which takes a little bit
of time you can see mostly the shade a
compilation card actually right so and
there's quite a lot of stuff here which
is cool I definitely don't like this see
deckle thing though it would be nice if
we could trim that and we definitely can
we just need to do some string
processing upon receiving the name about
of our function to actually trim that
calling convention because we've donated
and then maybe if it's a void function
we could even trim that let's see open
gel vertex array
okay so making the vertex oh yeah render
a 2d in it how long does that take 24
milliseconds I mean it's not that much
and then you know creating
compiling ash loading the texture so oh
this is creating the texture sorry
this is creating so say this is why it's
useful to know that's why I want to
cheese funk see because you can say that
we know that this is the OpenGL texture
to deconstructed it takes in two outside
integers which is of course the one
where we specify a size and then we
create it ourselves so it's not loading
in from a file what is it this thing oh
we're binding our index path oh cool
so that took like point one point zero
zero one milliseconds probably cuz I'm
actually doing is probably just queuing
out of the GPU and man let's see okay I
can just harried file so read file took
like point two milliseconds pretty quick
and in the actual shade a constructor
till 22 so it takes us about 22
milliseconds to actually create a shader
which is quite a lot of time so you know
you want to think about that that's
that's more than a frame so you
definitely don't to make that stuff on
the fly we are running in debug mode but
yeah shaded compile is taking like 21
milliseconds that's surprising that's
quite a lot interesting okay so then we
have what's this I'm gooey layer on
attach pusher overlay text your DB
anyway you guys can run this yourselves
and dig around with this I'm not going
to spend too long on this there's a
camera constructor you know we are
missing stuff like what's happening here
what's happening here you know this is
considerable amount of time not really
the point 1 milliseconds don't know if
you care about that I think it's not bad
it's between the it's between push layer
I guess is between apparently up the
constructor ends and then push layer
this is probably our constructor I'm not
sure why it's oh yeah because we didn't
yeah we actually put a profile in there
but it's probably this this is what's
running here which is why you know they
can do camera control gets managed to
initialize and all that stuff right here
but yeah that's gonna be out now our
constructor I guess push layer is
happening here which is you know
creating sandbox on - okay so this is
loading out thing right there's our s DB
I load that I wanted to have here that's
0.6 milliseconds and then the rest of it
you can see is actually creating the
OpenGL texture all right awesome so that
is our startup
let's look at shutdown because that'll
be nice
like I think okay so this here you can
see the time is reporting identical
start times which is what's causing this
so you definitely want to fix that up we
might do that next episode actually
we'll see how bad it is inside run time
render it should be shut down so what's
that doing up in gel texture destructor
you know shutting down the 2d renderer
takes like half a millisecond which
isn't bad
I'm GUI layout on detach is happening
here and then these true functions are
the let's see what we have here the
windows destructor and windows window
shutdown okay cool so that's that's kind
of our shutdown sequence that's what
happens it takes like you know what is
this 64 milliseconds which isn't too bad
and then finally the juicy part the run
time so there's the run time you can see
that it's all underneath what I just do
you it's all underneath this application
run umbrella and then we have each frame
you can see the frames are pretty full
because I put everything under run loop
there is all this empty space which
we'll investigate in a minute but yeah
we so we have okay well it's all under
swap buffers so you can see that swap
buffers is happening that's definitely
waiting for vsync that's why it's taking
that long there's no way we have enough
OpenGL commands to keep it busy but one
iteration here there's actually took 21
milliseconds which is considerable
that's above our facing time this one
though it took 12 milliseconds so was
below basing so it's kind of its kind of
looks like it's it's averaging out and
in fact you can view the average if we
just select all of these all right and
we look at the average Walter ation you
can see it's sixteen point nine
milliseconds which is pretty much right
at 60 frames per second so that's you
know at the facing being cold that one
not cold but waiting for this thing okay
cool so yeah mostly it's in windows
window on update and swap buffers
because again it has to wait to make
sure that we aren't running too quickly
and but then but then layer stack on
update which is doing a lot of the stuff
I guess the we're doing is you know one
point one four eight milliseconds and
what we have here we've got well the
graphic camera on update followed by
okay these are these are running at the
same time as well so we need to that's
to do with that and you can see this is
running at the same time so we really do
need to update our time
a little bit to make sure that it's not
recording identical start times
otherwise that's really screwing this up
of gel shredder satin matte for so what
is this this is a begin saying this is
begin saying around row draw inside
render it role which is begin saying yet
mostly and then there's the drop squad
that's happening so each quadrants
taking about 0.2 milliseconds which is
quite a lot for during the quad to gas
and then that's what's that so that's
doing all of that's probably okay set
floored for and then a bunch of time or
wonder what's in between there um I said
Matt for that's just doing math stuff
isn't it is it
this is Ren rotary draw quad what is
render a 2d draw for doing render a 2d
draw quad so except for for its binding
a texture I've got that profile right
yeah and then we're doing yeah we're
doing this so I guess this this this
kind of matrix maths took a bit of time
as well because that's gotta be what's
happening between between I guess
texture bind and the set mat for where
even is this is the texture bind isn't
it yeah texture binds the potential bind
is tiny it's like right here you kind of
see it it goes how how big is it it's
like tiny it doesn't even show up here
is like iteration it's tiny
so but then you know setting the
platform and then setting that my for
happens here with a bunch of GLM maths
going up going on around it yeah cool so
there you go so we now know that drawing
a quad takes you know that much time
cool I'm Glade begin happens here on I'm
going render happens here okay so this
is Li a stack as well layer stack on
update that's what I added manually into
where's application here it is okay so
run loop and then this is that edge the
brofist curve layer stack on update and
then layer stack on I'm GUI render so
that what we see over here
the layer stack on update and then just
layer stack on I include render so this
is the updating for the entire layer
stack and how long it takes in Intel's
ago Robert and then yeah
so there's kind of begin on i'm glenda
and then end and then we have sandbox to
do my Miranda which is like the only one
that's I guess actually rendering any
I'm doing stuff cool and then we have of
course like the next frame and a bowler
bar so you kind of get the point and
then this is obviously repeated for each
frame if we zoom out we have quite a lot
of frames of data and in fact if we want
to see how many frames we recorded we
can just look at this and it says that
we have run loop there's 369 occurrences
of it which means that we ran for 389
frames
cool so anyway hopefully now that we
have some actual data you can see what's
going on with hazel in the future it's
gonna be really interesting to compare
how long it takes to render like say 100
quads or a thousand quads with this
system versus the new render tree that
we're going to eventually implement
really cool to say this stuff obviously
went on at this stage and hazel where we
need to diagnose too much it's not a
particularly complicated engine and also
we're not at the point where we're
getting throttled like our performance
is getting throttled because you know
because we're doing something heavy
we're not doing any heavy lifting yet so
you can say this is a bit premature but
I didn't think so it's good to have the
system in here it's here if we want to
use it now there is that problem with
the timer returning the value a bit too
early well rather returning the same
values if we call you know high
resolution clock now multiple times in
like sequentially so we need to fix that
somehow if you guys want to have it go
fixing that and an archetypal request
that would be cool otherwise I might
address it in the next episode or in the
coming episodes or whatever but um yeah
hopefully you guys enjoyed this don't
forget to hit the like button if you did
and I will see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]